tonight on a special edition of Brian
Ross investigate the world saw what that
Minneapolis police officer did George
Floyd but will a jury see it the same
way
prosecutors are very reluctant to bring
cases against police officers especially
in homicide cases even with the dramatic
videos of police actions that lead to
death dozens of cases end up with the
fiddles or convictions on less serious
charges the difficult path to justice
Plus on a day George Floyd is buried and
remembered in Minneapolis
we'll hear from the widow of civil
rights leader and Congressman Elijah
Cummings who tells us what he would have
said if he was still alive we know
better we know better we know what's
good for our country we know what's good
for us plus our reporters being
purposely targeted by police will learn
this week's media winners and losers as
chosen by the editors of MIDI I'd see if
you agree from the law and crime Network
this is a special edition of Brian Ross
investigate thank you for joining us and
welcome to our viewers on YouTube live
and Facebook live i'm brian ross joined
today by my colleague at law and crime
rhonda schwartz Rhonda today was a day
where George Floyd was more under
Minneapolis the Reverend Al Sharpton
said to the country get your knees off
our neck that's right Brian and
political leaders celebrities mourners
of all ages came together to honor his
memory today with more with more
celebrations of his life to come in the
coming days and as that was going on in
Minneapolis 1,100 miles to the south in
Brunswick Georgia a preliminary hearing
for three men charged in the death of a
man armory a young black man who was
hunted down according to prosecutors and
executed in broad daylight on the
streets of an Atlanta suburb the hearing
went on throughout the day in the end
the judge ordered all three men bound
over to stand trial but it was quite a
case so joining us to talk about that
our two lawyers who have great
in this kind of law Eklund Mercy in
Atlanta of mercy law group and Kimberly
Whaley a former federal prosecutor CBS
News analyst and now a law professor
thank you both for joining us let's
start by listing some of the dramatic
testimony that took place today in
Georgia in the case with the special
agent in charge of the investigation
from the Georgia Bureau of Investigation
Richard Dahl describing some of the
racial slurs used by one of the men
accused in the murder
Travis McMichael stated on the crime
scene that was overheard by one of the
defendants in sheriff investigators
prior to police arriving correct
that's correct yes sir and though this
may be an uncomfortable conversation for
the benefit of a court in for the record
we're making it clear that this is not
your quote it's not the gpi's quote this
is a quote from a statement of mr.
Bryant as to what he heard Travis
McMichael say private police arriving
correct very much so yes sir
understanding that and understanding
that it might be a little uncomfortable
to talk about the words because it
involves a a curse word and something
else I need to ask you about that quote
can you please articulate for the court
what Mr Bryan said he heard Travis
McMichaels say prior to police arriving
after the fatal she yes um Mr Bryan said
that after the shooting took place
before police arrival while mr. Aubrey
was on the ground that he heard Travis
Michael make the statement fuckin
explosive testimony there from Richard
dial the Georgia Bureau of Investigation
agent handling the case let me ask you
both Eklund and Kimberly what do you
make of that and what role will that
have in the actual prosecution of these
three men Declan Oh I mean he they are
racist and that was premeditated you
don't say that after your you don't say
that that is racist and they should be
found guilty I feel that we we shouldn't
have any more conversations on it that
alone should seal the deal this was a
hate crime and should be looked as such
and Kimberly William askew as they bring
a murder charge in Georgia does the
racial animus
play a role or is it just a straight did
he shoot him or not well as Eckland
indicated for premeditated murderer
there has to be proof of a state of mind
it's generally harder to prove what
someone subjectively believed in the
moment and in this instance there's a
testimony to the effect that the
intention was racial prejudice was
targeting someone on the basis of their
skin color so that does go to common-law
murder which is what the state law would
bring but as far as a civil rights
charge we have indications from the
Department of Justice that there will be
potentially investigations into that
realm that would there it is against the
law as well to target people but by
virtue of hate in terms of violation of
civil rights that's right and the
testimony was explosive we had not heard
it before today's hearing in Georgia and
investigator dial on cross-examination
expanded on what he heard about Travis
McMichael yes for many times there's on
his Instagram post he responds on one I
do not recall every time it was there
but I can give you some examples of
numerous times he on the Instagram post
somebody sends him this is on January
2nd of 2020 someone sends him a video or
a picture we were not able to recover
that from the phone that's one of the
reasons why I haven't searched one out
for Instagram they send that out he says
makes the comment that would only be
better if they'd have owned that effing
in words or that ball and that in words
head off
and then he responds with that text this
is a histogram that you've identified
belonging to Travis of mine it's Greg
was always following - yes there are
several conversations and I do not they
were on the phone in our if they work
through instant messenger or through
text that I do not recall offhand but
one particular one that comes to mind is
he made the statement that he loved his
job because he was out on a boat and
there weren't any in words anywhere I
don't recall I don't recall again I
haven't reviewed his Coast Guard file a
very ugly development that testimony
today in Georgia Eklund in a week where
black Americans are feeling like the
knee of the world is on their neck
what's the impact of this kind of
testimony February this this happened in
February on Black History Month this
happened in February these facts were
these facts happen in February they
weren't arrested until May the anger is
real understand that that those officers
knew everything in February and they
want us to think that this justice is
February
that was clearly a racist attack they
they treated Ahmad like target practice
they are treating black people like
target practice and we they're treating
black people like target practice and it
wasn't until Gucci stores were burnt
it wasn't until things were disrupted
until they were arrested this is this is
why we are so angry this is why we have
an issue since February February that is
that is where we knew all this all these
facts he was looking for him the
Facebook post
it was there they have they have friends
and they are treating black people like
target practice that is what it is and
then y'all want to make it about the
flag that's what you want to make it
about people are dying because of things
that they can't have black skin I can't
take it off and you're killing me for it
that is what this is about and Kimberly
as you know is a former federal
prosecutors even things that looks so
clear we see the videos we know what
happened in this case in the case of the
George Floyd yet when you get in the
courtroom it can be different right it
sure can I mean you have to convince a
jury in this instance there's a lot of
public scrutiny on this for reasons that
eklund so compellingly described but as
you mentioned not only do we have Mr
Bryan testifying that those two words
were used over mr. Floyd's deceased body
on the car on the pavement we have a
videotape of what happened and then
we've got it sounds like from the
testimony today text messages instagrams
with racial slurs documents don't lie
and they don't die and they don't miss
remember this is not a hearsay is a
situation which in this instance would
would this a testimony mr. Bryan would
be admissible under a hearsay exception
but this is pretty overwhelming evidence
that there was not anything that
justified this brutality in fact in the
attempt to create a defense the defense
lawyers raised the question with the
investigator Richard Dyle whether mr. R
burry had some sort of mental illness
here's that back and forth
[Music]
we was self-defense by mr. Michael I
live with self-defense by mr. Oliver yes
I believe mr. Oliver was he pursued and
he Rangeley couldn't run anymore and
then turn him back to a man with a
shotgun or or fight with his bare hands
against the man to shotgun and he chose
to fight I think he has things to plead
mr. Aubrey's decision was to just try to
get away when he felt like he could not
escape chose to fight it is clear from
the investigation that for the driving
and the interactions that took place all
around that area that no shot was fired
at any time prior to amplify let me ask
you is a Georgia jury going to accept a
self-defense defense they could if
they're racist on there because here's
the UM the McMichaels they were on
Facebook groups groups of people agreed
with him groups of people voted along
with him groups of people liked his
comments groups of people said that
everything that he said was ok groups of
people talked him into hunting black
people and and and we have to believe
that we're gonna get a fair jury
I can't we can't get a fair jury it's
hard one let me tell you what happened
you had a black man tell a white woman
that the law was to leash her dog do you
understand how upset she got so these
are the type of people that we have to
think that we'll be on juries it's the
jury is the cross-section of your
population the surrounding community
that community we have to believe didn't
share their thoughts but come on like in
Brunswick the Confederate flags fly so
what
so now you can have overwhelming
evidence you have the best prosecutor
that was eloquent but it's the people
believe that because of his skin he
should have died if they are willing to
justify beyond anything that he was oh
that his death was okay this is we have
groups that are doing that that are
applauding McMichaels let me talk they
were did they have a fund do they have a
fund people are donating to the fund so
if they have funds how can I believe
that they're going to be they they don't
see a mod armory as a person they are
justifying his death when it was clearly
premeditated
let me get Kimberly wait let me ask you
that often is the case we've seen where
local juries will acquit police officers
or people accused in racially motivated
shootings and then the federal
government steps in as a former federal
prosecutor what would be the key things
the federal government prosecutors would
look for in a case like this to bring
their own charges well you know the
other alternative at the local level
which may or may not satisfy I'm
certainly not satisfied but address some
of the understandable outrage but on a
federal level it's against the law crime
to to knowingly violate someone's civil
rights and and that would be a hate
crime here and the court would be or
excuse me the prosecutors would be
looking to the evidence that eklund
mentioned that is overwhelming in this
moment that goes to racism and i think i
misspoke earlier when I mentioned mr.
Floyd every obviously this is mr. Aubrey
but but I think we're at a moment in
across the nation where white America in
this compilation of things in the same
moment where the president United States
is bringing federal officers
to bear on First Amendment right so that
he can sort of have a photo-op
in front of a church in the midst of a
pandemic I think white Americans are
realizing in ways that we haven't
collectively understood before how
deeply systemic and problematic and
corrosive and cancerous racism is and so
I think it would be a travesty in this
moment if the federal government didn't
the Justice Department didn't
investigate and bring its own charges
and certainly if they're what we call
jury nullification where jurors walked
away in light of the facts here mr.
Aubrey was doing nothing but running
jogging as an african-american it's
really extraordinarily painful and
shameful moment in American history and
let's hope where lots of other levers of
accountability are failing us as a
society in this moment we can at least
see these wrongdoers these three men
that murdered him in cold blood be
brought to justice
all right Kimberly Whaley and eklund
mercy thank you so much for joining us
fascinating insights we'll keep an eye
on this as a proceeds to trial and no
doubt the whole nation will be watching
what happens as the lawyers said today
so coming up I need four voices and
leadership one voice is missing that of
the great civil rights leader and
congressman Elijah Cummings but will
talk with his widow Maya Cummings about
what Elijah would have said you're
watching the law and crime trial Network
in a week and a half of ugly outrage
over protests looting and police
misconduct and brutality one important
voice is missing that of the former
congressman and civil rights leader
Elijah Cummings but his wife Maya
Cummings is carrying on tradition and I
talked with her earlier today dr. Maya
Cummings thank you so much for joining
us let me ask you what would your late
husband the great congressman Elijah
Cummings what would he have said after
watching what's happened in this country
over the last 10 days two weeks he would
have told protesters to focus on what
they're fighting for don't get
distracted by you know the people doing
the looting and the violence focus on
the larger message and the larger goal
which is justice which is certainly
valuing black lives and he would have
you know discouraged those who were
engaged in looting and violence because
he would have considered them
counterproductive to the larger message
he would have also said we're better
than this it's this popular refrain I've
noticed that a lot of politicians are
repeating it but he would have
absolutely deplored what Donald J Trump
did in response to the peaceful protest
going out so on outside of the White
House and he would have urged the
American public to you know basically
rise to a higher plane and focus on
making the solution the priority and he
would have joined with his colleagues in
the Congress not to focus on national
legislation and when he would say were
better than this it's inspirational what
do you really mean what he meant is that
we know better we know better we know
what's good for our country we know
what's good for us and that means that
we can do better and we can be better
and so Elijah was always one to see the
big picture and he felt strongly that if
we know better we can do better and we
can be better but we have to act so when
he's saying we're better than this it's
a call to our higher angels
to do us right and to serve justice
right now a lot of attention is being
focused on the prosecution of the four
officers in Minneapolis but we know from
cases around the country including in
Baltimore these prosecutions often are
not successful
in many cases charges aren't even
brought absolutely what happens in local
political ecosystems is there is a
political protection racket if you will
you know the the incestuous relationship
between the prosecutors and the police
departments is just very very tight so
tight that there's no arms distance
between them and prosecutors end up not
being you know able to politically
prosecute even if they had the will to
prosecute and so often times charges are
not brought up and what this ends up
being is basically a cycle of injustice
that ends up getting getting perpetuated
over time and that actually enrages the
population who often doesn't receive
justice and too often in places across
America it's African American
communities low-income black and brown
communities especially and you saw that
firsthand in Baltimore in the Freddie
gray case reminders of what happened
there and why so in 2015 Freddie gray
was a young African American who was
arrested for what no one can say and
they put him in the back of a paddy
wagon and and somewhere along the routes
of taking him from his neighborhood to
the detention center he was actually
violently injured in the back of the
police car of the police paddy wagon uh
and his neck was broken he ended up
going to the hospital and dying several
days later and so with that you know the
public was enraged how could someone who
was perfectly fine when he entered a
paddy wagon the end up being uh you know
basically violently injured by the time
he got to the destination and then of
course ended up dying so Elijah ended up
going out on the streets and I was
actually there with him to walk with the
protesters to make sure that he was in
between the protesters and the law
enforcement officers who were fully
geared up in riot gear so that there
wouldn't be no conflagration that would
cause a city to just basically explode
and so he basically put his body on the
line and his voice and his credibility
on the line to make sure that he could
keep the peace and prevent the city from
going up in flames what ended up
happening after several nights of the
unrest like we saw in Minneapolis and
other places around the country it was
here in Baltimore five years ago the
city's newly elected prosecutor who was
progressive decided to bring charges
against the officers and all of a sudden
a tense situation wherein largely at
lower income african-american community
who is ready to go toe-to-toe with the
officers ended up becoming a celebration
the day the night that that Marilyn
Mosby decided to prosecute the officers
because finally the african-american
community felt like somebody was
listening to them finally they felt like
somebody was willing to serve justice
and finally they felt like that the law
might finally be working on their side
and yet the charges were dropped and yet
the charges were dropped
that new prosecutor was maligned she was
harassed she was you know certainly you
know they went after her law license she
you know tried her best to continue with
the prosecution at the end of the day
she said that she had to drop the
charges because she got no cooperation
from the police department and that they
were actively seeking to undermine her
investigation in the fraternal order of
the police the police union was actually
after her as well there was a lot of
division here in the city of Baltimore
with the wealthier and the wider
neighborhoods unwilling to support her
efforts to prosecute those police
officers and the african-american
community found themselves warded yet
again and that's the issue of justice
being thwarted yet again and finally you
haven't given up hope he wouldn't have
given up hope I have not given up hope
and Elijah would not have either and so
you know I will continue to speak up and
speak out I will continue to leverage
any kind of role that I have to make
sure that we are building a society
is inclusive of all we can't afford we
are now a very diverse pluralistic
society we can't afford to have one
system of justice that works for people
that are wider and wealthier and another
system of justice that does not work for
black and brown and low-income people
and so if we're going to be committed to
a diverse and inclusive future then we
need to be committed to a legal system
that applies the law fairly across all
populations no matter who you are what
you look like or how much money you have
in your pocket dr. Maier comments thank
you so much for joining us tonight Brian
thank you for your leadership coming up
we'll talk about why it's so difficult
to prosecute police misconduct and then
the media winners and losers as chosen
by the editors of MIDI I see if you
agree you're watching the long crime
trial Network
hours after Chris Watts a husband and
father made a plea for his missing wife
and daughters safe return I want those
kids back so that police now consider
him a suspect he said when he left she
was in bed sleeping thority say his
story just doesn't add up
back now the police and the FBI do a
good job of tracking all kinds of crimes
robberies murders kidnappings car thefts
but they don't really do much of a job
in tracking police crime brutality
allegations against police the one
person who does do that is a professor
at Bowling Green University Phyllis
Tinson who's made it his mission to keep
an eye on what's going on with police
charged with either murder or
manslaughter and I talked with him
earlier this week
professor Phil Stenson thank you so much
for joining us as the Minnesota Attorney
General keith ellison has said bringing
the cases there against the police
officers will be no slam dunk you know
that right absolutely you know I've been
studying this for about 15 years and
what we see in these cases when
prosecutors are willing to bring cases
in homicide cases against police
officers they're willing to step back
from their usual role where they're
thinking about can we get a conviction
and they're realizing these are gonna be
difficult cases to obtain a conviction
but we're going forward with the case
anyway because our job is to seek
justice and I think that's what we see
here you studied more than 100 cases
where officers were arrested charged
with murder or manslaughter what was the
outcome there when we look at the cases
where officers are charged with murder
and manslaughter resulting from an
on-duty shooting which is not the case
here we've got a hundred and ten cases
where officers were charged since 2005
and to date only 42 of those officers
have been convicted and just five of the
officers have actually been convicted of
murder so when we see these cases
generally with homicide cases and
on-duty police officers they're often
convicted of a lesser charge and frankly
it's a very rare event when an officer
is charged in the first place as you
know that first time we heard that
phrase I can't breathe
involve the case in Staten Island what
happened there well in that case we have
a different type of situation because we
have a gentleman who was being arrested
which was crazy why he was being
arrested it was for selling loose
cigarettes and not collecting sales tax
as I recall but there I would
distinguish the case in Minnesota from
what happened to Eric Gardner and Staten
Island in that in the case with Eric
Gardner they were still trying to get
him handcuffed and I think that's how
the officer escaped responsibility
in many regards was never prosecuted
criminally was because they were still
trying to get Eric Gardner to comply to
get him handcuffed here we have a
completely different situation where mr.
Floyd was no threat to the officers at
all he was already handcuffed and the
only reason they removed him from the
cruiser apparently and got him down on
the ground was to invoke a little street
justice in other words to teach him a
lesson to rough him up and as we see it
got completely out of hand and resulted
in his death and in the case with Eric
Gardner no charges against the officers
either local or federal that's true only
administrative discipline within the
NYPD what is the reason that these
crises are so difficult for one
prosecutors to bring into when they
actually get to a jury we see so many
acquittals well you know we saw in a
case involving an officer named Mohammed
nor out of Minneapolis a few years ago
where the local prosecutor Mike Freeman
he talked about this at a press
conference when he brought charges and
he said for the first time in his career
he realized that his office that his
attorneys that the investigators in the
prosecutor's office were getting
stonewalled from the police department
they were the police department the
investigators the detectives within the
police department were not cooperating
with the prosecutor's office so we're
seeing that in some cases where
prosecutors are having difficulty simply
putting their case together because they
can't get cooperation from the local
police department which is as you know
Brian a difficult situation because
prosecutors in their day to day work
have to rely on police officers to bring
any case against anyone in so many of
these cases there are videos and the
public sees them and think well this
obviously is something wrong here talk
about that case in Cleveland 12 year-old
tomorrow ice he was shot by a police
officer yeah now that case I would
distinguish as well I mean people don't
like to bring this up because we don't
like it when a 12 year old is killed by
police officers they never should have
approached the 12 year old as they did
but he was carrying a toy gun but what
we see with these cases where the videos
are quite obvious that a crime has been
committed where we all think it's a slam
dunk that an officer is going to be
convicted at trial it doesn't work out
that way quite often because what we see
in jury trials is that juries are very
reluctant to second-guess the
split-second life
decisions of an on-duty police officer
in a potentially violent street
encounter and oddly enough we see the
same phenomenon in bench trials where
judges are sitting as the Trier of fact
without a jury in no case as an officer
been convicted of murder or manslaughter
in the last 15 years as a result of an
on-duty shooting when there's been a
bench trial we've had several cases
where officers have been convicted or
have been acquitted at a bench trial but
never convicted so these are very very
difficult cases to obtain convictions
talking about the case involving George
Floyd in Minneapolis the prosecutor the
state the district attorney a state
attorney has now decided to bring
second-degree murder charges against him
and the other three officers there will
be charged with aiding and abetting the
second-degree murder the world has seen
that video but on the other hand some
argue that well the video shows that he
was obviously doing this in plain sight
he knew people were watching him he
can't have been trying to kill him well
it's an interesting thing you know I've
seen over and over again in recent years
where officers are well aware that
they're being recorded on video and they
go ahead and commit a crime anyway we've
seen that in numerous instances where
officers were recorded with their own
body worn cameras committing crimes so
it seems that police officers over time
really don't think about the video
recorders that are present the officers
had every reason to know that there were
multiple citizen bystanders with
smartphones recording on video the the
bystanders were trying to engage the
officers in a colloquy trying to to talk
to the officers trying to reason with
the officers to stop and yet we see the
officers just continue on we see the
officer continue with his knee in the in
the back and the in the knee into the
neck and we see that the other officers
just stand by so it also tells me that
the other officers standing by and doing
nothing is very it's very troubling it's
an indication that the police subculture
in Minneapolis normalizes this type of
behavior that Street just is teaching
somebody a lesson for giving them a hard
time or their perception that somebody
gave them a hard time and need to be
taught a lesson
apparently it's business as usual that's
the only thing that I can conclude when
I watch that video
and finally what's special protections
under the law do police officer have
been carrying out their duties well
under the relevant Supreme Court case
law so under Tennessee versus Gardner
and Graham versus Connor two cases from
the 1980s a police officer is justified
in using deadly force if the officer has
a reasonable apprehension of an eminent
threat of serious bodily injury or
deadly force being used against the
officer or someone else and the court
has said that that's a standard of
objective reasonableness in other words
with a police officer was acting
reasonably without the benefit of
hindsight so here I think we'll see
potentially that the defense will raise
that issue that somehow there was a
threat but I don't see how that's going
to carry much weight because as we all
watch that video clearly mr. Floyd was
of no threat at all to the officers but
based on your research and what happens
in so many of these cases where someone
is charged with murder or manslaughter
the outlook is not particularly
optimistic right in terms of a
conviction now what we see actually in
the cases where multiple officers are
charged and we've seen this over the
last 15 years we saw it in 2007 in
Atlanta and we saw it around the same
time in New Orleans with the Danziger
bridge cases when we see and a few
others frankly when we see multiple
officers charged quite often what
happens is the state cases get botched
for one reason or another they don't get
a conviction or they don't get a
sentence that's a very long sentence and
and then the US attorney will come in
and there will be criminal charges
potentially at the federal level
criminal deprivation of civil rights
conspiracy those types of things and it
would not surprise me at all in this
instance if we see federal charges
against the officers as well all right
professor Phil Stinson thank you so much
for joining us fascinating insights
thank you
coming up this week's winners and losers
in the media see if you agree what the
editor in chief of media has to say
about Laura Ingraham of Fox News you're
watching the long crime trial Network
hours after Chris wants a husband and
father made a plea for his missing wife
and daughters safe return I want those
kids back so bad police now consider him
a suspect he said when he left she was
in bed sleeping for --'tis say his story
just doesn't add up
back now with our winners and losers in
the media this week as chosen by the
editor-in-chief and the editors at media
I'd Aidan mcLaughlin thank you for
joining us today
hey Brian this quite a week for
reporters covering what's been going on
in the country with apparently seemingly
being targeted by police themselves yes
this has really been the big story for
us covering this week you know over the
weekend a lot of the protests turned
into sort of violent clashes between
police and protesters and what is
particularly alarming for us violent
clashes between police and reporters so
you know a couple of our winners in this
category especially the early part of
the week when when you know that there
was a the unrest was a little bit more
chaotic our reporters who were on the
front lines of these protests and the
clashes between police and protesters
and actually either you know got in
harm's way because of police or because
of protesters using things like
fireworks so that we actually settled
out to MSNBC personalities Garrett Haake
and Ali Velshi who got targeted during
these protests and I don't know if we
have video let's take a look at that
video yeah you're we doing let's take a
look at that it sounds like this thing
and do it do it like they're daring the
state troopers to fire on them again
let's come back out for just a minute
Ali Velshi is standing by on the scene
with us and of course not the only
reporters targeted some got hit by
rubber bullets one reporter lost an eye
after hit by a rubber bullet and another
MSNBC reporter right yeah Garrett Haake
got hit by some sort of projectile in
his side and you know it's these are
examples of reporters being on the front
lines covering these things in the thick
of it particularly you know Ali Velshi
is an anchor on MSNBC most of the time
you see him behind the desk so it was
pretty astonishing to see him reporting
live from the field and to be caught in
the crossfire between the police who are
shooting these rubber bullets at
protesters and hitting journalists I
will say that you know this was a really
unfortunate and sort of disappointing
act on behalf of police to just fire
sort of rubber bullets indiscriminately
and hit journalists but there are more
egregious examples if you look at
Washington DC when police cleared out
protesters from Lafayette Square before
President Donald Trump did his walk to
the church there was an actual an
Australian news crew that got pretty
badly beaten by police with Ryan
Reynolds and it actually got caught on
live television on an ABC news feed so
there are examples of you know these
MSNBC hosts who are you know so close to
the action that they're getting hit by
rubber bullets which is inexcusable but
what's even worse is when you have these
Australian news crews we're getting
deliberately targeted by police and this
you know the guy that got beaten by a
part policeman actually had a large
camera and was clearly filming the
protests so it's pretty unacceptable all
around but it's it's still a win for
them that they're really out there
reporting on this because we really it's
really important to have eyes on the
ground they've become like combat
reporters covering the protests in the
cities of America in fact the audience
in Australia was what the audience in
Australia was watching live and their
morning show as this was taking place
wondering what
in the world is going on in America yeah
and it's pretty it was also pretty
jarring to see the Scottish Prime
Minister Prime Minister Morrison who
said that there would be an
investigation into what happened with
police beating on Australian news crew
which is really not something you want
to read about the United States about
you know foreign countries the their
leaders having to launch investigations
about police brutality against
journalists that should be you know the
baseline for a democracies that police
don't indiscriminately target
journalists and the video of course was
always so dramatic let's take a look at
what happened to Jolin Kent
[Music]
lots of brave reporters out there at the
same time one of your losers this week
was a surprise to many people the New
York Times the bastion of journalism
that's right now the New York Times has
been getting a lot of heat this week you
know I think I want to look at what
happened towards the end of this week
they published an opinion piece by Tom
cotton the headline of that was send in
the troops and it was basically calling
for the ordering for the military to
come in and essentially crack down on
the protests now I think that sort of
sound that sounds quite wild now even
because I feel like a lot of the
protests have calmed down and they're
not in the same position that they were
at towards the beginning of the week so
they're having they're facing a sort of
revolt now amongst staff who are saying
that that publishing that Tom cotton
op-ed is putting the lives of their
journalists in danger now the reason we
gave them the the loser towards the
beginning of the week was for actually a
headline that that got a huge amount of
criticism that they ran on the front
page it was the cover of the New York
Times earlier this week and it was
Tuesday morning it came out following
President Donald Trump's basically photo
stunt that he pulled where protesters
were sort of violently cleared from
Franklin Square City who walked to a
church and the New York Times headlined
did a really bad job of capturing what
was happening there so they took a lot
of backlash for that and it was at yet
another example of something that Dean
bouquet the editor of The Times has said
that they strive to avoid which is
really not capturing the sort of the the
news and the the atrocity of a story by
having a sort of both sides headline
that mutes sort of bad actions on behalf
of the chemical and what's so
interesting to me is that the sort of
the uprising within the ranks of the New
York Times by the younger group of
reporters this never would have happened
in the olden days at the New York Times
sure I mean I think it's a social media
fueled development I think the fact that
all of these young reporters have a
voice on a platform that's not the New
York Times where they can speak out and
criticize decisions made by the paper
you also have to remember that you know
there's the opinion page at the time to
run by James Bennett who's getting all
of this criticism for that Tom cotton
op-ed and the newsroom which is run by
Dean bouquet the executive editor of the
paper and you know it's a mostly
reporters in the newsroom that are
criticizing this often but it's also a
lot of people that write for the opinion
page that are you know questioning why
the New York Times gave a platform to
Tom cotton now the argument that James
Bennett is making is that Tom cotton is
a powerful person who was in charge of
setting policy for the United States and
it would be sort of silly to to not give
him a voice and to sort of basically
shield your eyes from his opinions the
counter-argument is that you know his
opinions are especially the ones
expressed in this op-ed are some of them
are misleading and some of them are
appear dangerous because he's actually
calling for the military to be sent into
these protests and to crack down on them
pair that with a lot of the brutality
that we've seen used against journalists
I think you can understand why the New
York Times newsroom is upset about this
right just a couple of minutes left here
Aidan you gave a winner's uh laurel to
CNN
sure and actually if I could just break
up this the order that we're going in
here and could we focus on Laura camper
up a little bit so I've something to get
off my brain yeah tell her we made the
loser on Wednesday and we made FoxNews
again the loser today for two things
that that Laura Ingraham has done this
week and it's basically this you know
she spoke out and said that the tear gas
was not used on the protesters that were
cleared from Franklin Square
so that President Donald Trump could
have the photo walking from the church
now she actually called a meteorite and
demanded a correction because we ran a
story that that basically said you know
she was saying
tear gas wasn't used and reporters on
the ground who were you know coughing
and crying because tear gas was used
were fact-checking her now she based her
claim that tear gas wasn't used on the
park police who came out and issued a
statement saying that uh no no no it was
just smoke canisters and pepper balls
that were used not to your gas now the
CDC considers pepper spray a form of
teargas right so it's sort of a silly
semantic argument it becomes a little
bit more dangerous when you consider
that that semantic argument is made to
cover up for an administration cracking
down on peaceful protesters and
journalists now aside from the sepia you
made her one of your big losers there's
yeah it's what no doubt a chemical agent
for sure well she said a lot of things
that have been called into question and
she doesn't seem to be bothered by any
of the criticism aid Magatha I want to
thank you so much so fast in any week
we'll have you back here again next week
really do appreciate it that's it for
our program Jesse represented our thanks
to all everybody for watching and to our
staff for getting us on the air and off
the air
[Music]
you